so maybe taking a step back we talked
about
the nobel prize with accelerating
universe but uh your work
and the ideas around supernova
were important
uh in detecting this accelerating
universe
can we go to the very basics of what is
this
uh beautiful mysterious object of a
supernova right so
a supernova is an exploding star most
stars die a relatively quiet death our
our own sun will despite the fact that
it'll become a red giant and incinerate
earth it'll do that
reasonably slowly but there's a small
minority of stars that
end their lives in a titanic explosion
and that's not only exciting to watch
from afar
but it's critical to our existence
because it is in these explosions that
the heavy elements
synthesize through nuclear reactions
during the normal course of the star's
evolution and during the explosion
itself
get ejected into the cosmos making them
available
as raw material for new stars planets
and
ultimately life you know and that's just
a great story
um the best in in some ways so
you know we like to study these things
and and our origins
but it turns out these are incredibly
useful beacons as well
because if you know how powerful
uh an exploding star really is by
measuring
the apparent brightness at its peak in
galaxies whose distances we already know
through having
made other measurements and you can thus
calibrate how powerful the thing really
is
and then you find ones that are much
more distant
then you can use their observed
brightness
compared with their true intrinsic power
or luminosity
to judge their distance and hence the
distance of the galaxy in which they're
located
so okay it's like looking at if you'll
uh let me just give this one analogy
you know you judge the distance of an
oncoming car at night
by looking at how bright its headlights
appear to be
and you've calibrated how bright the
headlights are
of a car that's two or three meters away
of known distance and you go oh that's a
faint headlight and so that's pretty far
away
you also use the apparent angular
separation between the two headlights as
a consistency check in your brain but
that's what your brain is doing
so we can do that for cars we can do
that for stars
nice i like that but you know with cars
the headlights are all
there's some variation there's but but
uh they're
somewhat similar so you can make those
kinds of conclusions
what uh how much uh variation is there
between supernova that you can
yeah that and can you detect them right
so first of all there are several
different ways that stars can
explode and it depends on their mass and
whether they're in a binary system and
things like that
and the ones that we used for these
cosmological purposes
studying the expansion of the history of
the universe
are the so-called type roman numeral 1
lowercase a type 1a supernovae
they come from a weird type of a star
called a white dwarf
our own sun will turn into a white dwarf
in about 7 billion years
it'll have about half its present mass
compressed into a volume
just the size of earth so that's an
inordinate density okay it's incredibly
dense
and the matter is what's called by
quantum physicist degenerate matter
not because it's morally reprehensible
or anything like that but this is just
the
judgments here yeah quantum physicists
give to electrons that are squeezed into
a very tight
space the electrons take on emotion due
to heisenberg uncertain heisenberg's
uncertainty principle
and also due to the pauli exclusion
principle that
electrons don't like to be in the same
place they like to avoid each other so
those two things
mean that a lot of electrons are moving
very rapidly
which gives the star an extra pressure
far above the thermal pressure
associated with just the random motions
of
particles inside the star so it's a
weird type of star
but normally it wouldn't explode and our
sun won't
explode except that if such a white
dwarf
is in a pair with another more or less
normal star
it can steal material from that
normal star until it gets to an unstable
limit
roughly one and a half times the mass of
our sun
1.4 or so this is known as the
chandrasekhar
chandrasekhar limit after subramanyan
chandrasekhar
an indian astrophysicist who figured
this out when he was about 20 years old
on a voyage from india to england where
he was to be educated
and then he did this and then 50 years
later he won the nobel prize
in physics in 1984 largely for this work
okay that he did as a youngster who was
on his way to be educated
you know oh and his advisor the great
arthur eddington
in england who had done a lot of great
things and was a great astrophysicist
nevertheless
he too was human and had his faults he
ridiculed chandra's scientific work
at a conference in england and you know
most of us if we had been chandra would
have just
given up astrophysics at that time you
know when the great arthur eddington
you know ridicules our our work and
that's another
inspirational story for the youngster
you know just just keep going you know
but anyway your advisors yeah no matter
what your advisor says right
so or don't always pay attention to your
advisor right don't
don't be uh don't lose hope if you
really think you're on to something
that doesn't mean never listen to your
advisor they may have sage advice as
well
but anyway um you know when a white
dwarf
grows to a certain mass it becomes
unstable and one of the ways
it can end its life is to go through a
thermonuclear runaway
so basically the carbon nuclei inside
the white dwarf starts start fusing
together to form heavier
nuclei and the energy that those fusion
reactions
emit emits
doesn't go into um you know
being dissipated out of the star or you
know whatever
uh or expanding it the way you know if
you take a blow torch to the middle of
the sun
you heat up its gases the gases would
expand and cool
but this degenerate star can't expand
and cool and so the energy pumped in
through these fusion reactions
goes into making the nuclei move faster
and that
gets more of them sufficiently close
together that they can undergo nuclear
fusion
thereby releasing more energy that goes
into
speeding up more nuclei and thus you
have a a runaway
uh a bomb an uncontrolled
fusion reactor right instead of the
controlled fusion which is what our sun
does
okay our sun is a marvelous controlled
fusion reactor this is what we need here
on earth
fusion energy to solve our energy crisis
right
but the sun holds the stuff in you know
through gravity and you need a big mass
to do that
so this un uncontrolled fusion reaction
blows up a star that's pretty much the
same
in all cases and you measure it
to be almost the same in all cases but
the devil is in the details
and in fact we observe them to not be
all the same
and theoretically they might not be all
the same because
the rate of the fusion reactions might
depend on the
amount of trace heavier elements in the
white dwarf and that could depend on how
old it is when it was
you know whether it was born billions of
years ago when there weren't many
heavier elements
or whether it's a relatively young white
dwarf and
all kinds of other things and part of my
work was to show that indeed
not all the type 1as are the same you
have to be careful
when you use them you have to calibrate
them they're not
standard candles the way it just
if all headlights or all candles were
the same
lumens or whatever you'd say they're
standard and then it would be the
candle is an awesome term okay standard
candles is what astronomers like to say
the night sky i don't like that term
because there aren't any standard
candles but there are standardizable
candles
and by looking at these calibrating them
that's calibratable standardizable
calibratable you look at enough of them
in nearby galaxies
whose distances you know independently
and
what you can tell is that you know this
is something that a colleague of mine
mark phillips did
who was on schmidt's team and arguably
one of the was one of the people who
deserved the nobel prize but
he showed that the intrinsically more
powerful type 1as
decline in brightness and it turns out
rise in brightness as well
more slowly than the less luminous 1as
and so
if you calibrate this by measuring a
whole bunch of nearby ones
and then you look at a distant one
instead of saying
well it's a 100 watt type 1a supernova
they're much more powerful than that by
the way
plus or minus 50 you can say no it's
it's 112
plus or minus 15. or it's or it's 84
plus or minus 17. it tells you where it
is
in the power scale and it greatly
decreases
the uncertainties and that's what makes
these things cosmologically useful
i showed that if you spread the light
out into a spectrum
you can tell spectroscopically that
these things are different as well
and in 1991 i happened to study
two of the extreme peculiar ones the
low luminosity ones and the high
luminosity ones
1991 bg and 1991
t this showed that not all the 1as are
the same and indeed
at the time of 1991 i was a little bit
skeptical
that we could use type 1as because of
this diversity that i was observing
but in 1993 mark phillips wrote a paper
that showed this correlation between
the light curve the brightness versus
time and the
peak luminosity and which gives you
enough information to calibrate yeah
then they become calibratable and that
was a game changer how many type 1as are
out there
to use for data now there are thousands
of them thousands
of time the high z team had 16
and the supernova cosmology project had
40.
but the 16 were better measured than the
40 and so
our statistical uncertainties were
comparable if you look at the two papers
that were published how does that
make you uh feel that there's these
gigantic explosions
just sprinkled out there is that well i
certainly don't want one to be very
nearby
and it would have to be within something
like 10 light years to be
an existential threat so they can happen
in our
uh galaxy oh yeah yeah you know so we
would be okay
uh in most cases we'd be okay because
our galaxy is a hundred thousand light
years across
okay and you'd need one of these things
to be within about 10 light years to be
an existential threat and it gives birth
to
a bunch of other stars i guess
yeah it gives birth to expanding gases
that are chemically enriched and those
expanding gases
mix with other chemically enriched
expanding gases or
primordial clouds of hydrogen and helium
you